video games being banned for excessive
violent religious reasoning offer
over-the-top sexiness has become
commonplace in gaming society we have in
place classification organizations who
outline the suitability of each game for
example the US has ESRB
Europe has the peggy system and japan
uses a serie of scheme amongst other
agencies occasionally video games make
the front cover of newspapers or
national news for the wrong reasons with
that in mind here are 10 shocking video
games that were crushed by the banhammer
be warned some of these titles are a
little disgusting immoral blasphemous or
downright criminal here we go
first on our list is harvester released
back in 1996 hiding behind the veil of a
point-and-click adventure in a 1950s
town you play as Steve who has amnesia
our so-called hero meanders around the
town talking to locals who are little
eccentric to say the least for example
one gentleman has a spike hole into his
daughter's bedroom while she has guests
over another inhabitant is the proud
mother of three children who are slowly
eating her alive and there are even
disgusting murder scenes which would
rival MORTAL KOMBAT finishes when asked
about Harvester the creator Gilbert P
Austin stated he wanted the game to
serve as an examination of the
controversy about whether violence in
media creates or is created by violence
in society pretty deep stuff harvester
gained a cult following and is still
played on YouTube if you could stomach
it next up is portal 2 which describes
itself as a black comedy first-person
shooter in this outing you play as
portal dude who lives in a trailer park
in Arizona you are given menial tasks to
complete such as get milk buy food or
treat your gonorrhea but those become
more outrageous the longer you play so
why was this band well it's the violence
so much violence from decapitating
enemies and using their heads as
footballs to urinating on Gary Coleman
there's something to disgust everyone oh
did I mention that you can use a cat's
backside as a gun suppressor it's true
the Tom Clancy games could learn a lot
from postal New Zealand were one of the
first countries to ban postal 2 back in
2004 stating ownership and distribution
of
game is a criminal offence punishable by
up to ten years in prison we can't avoid
censorship in the UK either which is
evident in one of my personal favorite
games th Q's The Punisher back in the
ps2 days Marvel's antihero would murder
and maim his way through everyone the
key issue in terms of censorship was the
interrogation mechanic which let the
Punisher dangle enemies from buildings
crush them under window pins and even
push them into grinders just for
information here's some other ways to
extract information in the Punisher even
though the game was given an 18 rating
many of the interrogation scenes were
adapted to allow for a worldwide release
back in 2005 the game guy is a terrible
video game which is a quiz show based
around titillation released on ps2 Xbox
and PC your quest is to answer trivia
questions
nothing could be wrong with that right
well you are gifted with videos of
scantily clad young women who assist you
with answers still I'll care by your
standards if you successfully answer
enough questions correctly then those
young women will expose their
breasticles to you of course it wasn't
long until a lawsuit turned up but this
is where the story becomes a little more
sinister and criminal it turns out that
one of the girls in the video was only
17 and therefore a minor and underage
bloody shocking I know
top-heavy Studios released a DVD to
circumvent the video game censorship but
thankfully no one bought that okay that
got a little bit dark there so let's
bring things back with the smearing of
another nations ideals Battlefield 4 was
and still is a fantastic fps
but people in China may not know that in
the main campaign you play as an
American Marine who uncovers a plot to
kill a Chinese presidential delegate
that alone doesn't seem like a reason to
ban the game but with the free dlc China
rising in which the fighting takes place
in China the Chinese government banned
the game due to discredit ation of their
national sovereignty and even noted that
the majority of games would use Germany
as
historical enemy and Russia has a
modern-day enemy but this is slowly
becoming China who is the enemy and they
don't want to be seen like that by the
rest of the world I can see their logic
there I really come back to high-impact
violence and in 2015 the game hatred was
released on PC it is an isometric
shooter mode where you play as a
disturbed man with no backstory who is
sick and tired of humanity I think you
know where this is going don't you well
the unnamed protagonist decides to arm
himself with an ak-47 a handful of
grenades and a knife and begins a
killing spree across New York if that
wasn't a bad enough reason to burn the
game then the way to regenerate health
would be the player is rewarded with
health every time they execute someone
what really made this game difficult for
me was the lack see Daisy cook killing
of civilians unarmed and unaware
civilians
truly gut-wrenching Australia banned
this game of course as they ban
everything but then the publisher
devolver digital banned the game
outright
let's stick with devolver digital for
our next entry prepare yourself for this
genital jousting yep
you are really seeing this genital
jousting in which you play a penis and
the hitters I can't bring myself to
explain any further so just just enjoy
devolver digital have decided to read
you'd lock this game so Australia you
won't be getting this anytime soon I
can't decide if you're missing out or
not Australia
I really can't if you've ever watched
South Park you understand the level of
humor and shock value tread park and
matt stone use
so when South Park the stick of truth
was announced no one knew how much of
the game would be censored or banned
completely Ubisoft decided to censor the
game before it could be released with
only the American version remaining
intact the German version had all Nazi
references removed including the
swastika and Nazi salutes which
coincidentally are illegal in Germany I
didn't know that did you
many other versions were edited
including the anal probe section and a
scene involving abortion did you be soft
and Obsidian spend hours censoring each
scene no not at all they simply used a
censor card this was in keeping with the
show's comedy element and really added
to each scene very surprising number two
I nope nope move on I am NOT talking
about that look at the title of the game
there's a clue there there is no chance
I'm talking about that move on and to
finish I had to choose the controversy
that engulfed the world mortal kombat
back in 1992 a small game came out using
seemingly real-life characters as they
fought to the death yes I know they
don't look real compared to modern-day
graphical capabilities but in 1994 this
was cutting edge in fact this was
bleeding edge see where did they do to
countless lawsuits and court cases
mortal kombat became a must-have because
everyone told us we couldn't have it
Australia of course immediately banned
the game and the rest of the world spent
countless hours talking about it to a
point where everyone became desensitized
more than 20 years later and Mortal
Kombat is a staple part of our videogame
diet continuously trying to shock us
with
Gouri deaths and broken bones are we
shocked anymore
please let me know your thoughts in the
comment below and have I missed a game
off this list that you think should be
on it please let me know when I started
making this video I did not expect to
find games which actually offended and
disgusted me but surprisingly I did now
well well now I have to explain my
google search history to my girlfriend
and probably the police - I'm Adam from
police station grenade I'll see you next
time